merci beaucoup pauline on se retrouve
tout à l'heure 7h30 pour un prochain
journal pour l'heure c'est l'heure de la
revue de presse
mais vous l'avez vu à mes côtés julien
chez ida bonjour julien jours damien on
commence cette revue de presse
internationale avec cette histoire de
braquage au liban histoire symptomatique
de la crise économique que traverse le
pays depuis trois ans mais effectivement
braquage peu ordinaire qui s'est passé
hier matin à beyrouth et que nous
raconte libération ça s'est passé dans
un quartier assez fréquentée de la
capitale une jeune femme a braqué je
cite sa propre camp propre banque pardon
pour venir récupérer son argent après 30
minutes elle est repartie avec 13000
euros ce qui est intéressant dans cette
histoire est bien c'est le motif d'abord
à lille elle a dit que c'était pour
financer le traitement contre le cancer
de sa soeur et la raison aussi pourquoi
retirer de l'argent vire un braquage et
bien tout simplement parce que la banque
refusait de lui donner accès à son
compte bancaire elle ne pouvait en
raison de la crise économique qui frappe
le pays depuis plus depuis plusieurs
années elle ne pouvait retirer que 200
euros par mois finalement l'opération
s'est déroulée sans blesser avec un
pistolet automatique qui était en fait
un pistolet en plastique de son neveu
c'est donc un geste désespéré écrit le
journal symbole d'un pays à la dérive
beaucoup de libanais d'ailleurs ont
salué cet acte oui 200 euros par mois
maximum c'est le sort de tous les
libanais d'ailleurs et dans la presse la
jeune femme explique son geste oui c'est
l'histoire d'une femme prête à tout je
vous le disais pour sauver sa soeur dans
un pays je cite l'orient le jour le
quotidien libanais dans un pays dont la
chute est de plus en plus absurde elle
s'appelle s'allie à la 28 ans et une
architecte d'intérieur connu aussi pour
ses activités comme activiste dans les
mouvements de contestation qui touche le
pays depuis 2010 9 elle évoque un geste
de la dernière chance longtemps préparée
en amont avec l'appui de plusieurs
organisations elle est aujourd'hui sur
le coup d'une arrestation mais elle dit
ne rien regretter et en france
maintenant le gouvernement cherche à
éviter à tout prix une crise de
l'énergie qui pourrait bousculer
l'économie les annonces d'elisabeth
bande étaient très attendus comme on
l'est commente la presse on peut dire
que les réactions sont assez mitigés
damien à l'image de libération qui parle
d'abord d'une touche tiède oui les
français seront en partie protégé
l'hiver prochain mais le gouvernement ne
pourra pas absorber en totalité la
hausse des prix et du gaz et de
l'électricité
c'est un début écrit le journal mais
pour l'humanité bien céder bien plus
critique tout ça c'est du bricolage je
cite le titre du quotidien fondé par
jean jaurès car non seulement les
français vont payer davantage mais en
plus de ça on leur demande de consommer
moins avec ce même objectif de réduction
estimée de 10 % de notre consommation
même constat pour la provence qui
annonce un coup de froid aussi bien sur
le plan économique que sur celui du
confort notamment ce qui concerne les
logements qu'on écrit comme des
passoires thermiques du coup tous à
damien ça donne du grain à moudre
dessinateur de presse avec ce dessin de
cas qu en une de l'opinion avec un
dialogue entre le président de la
république et sa première ministre
emmanuel macron disant est ce qu'on a de
quoi passer l'hiver à lui répond d'une
manière ou d'une autre ça va
certainement chauffer notamment à cause
du climat social qui s'annonce déjà
tendue à l'automne est d'ailleurs n'y a
pas qu'en france que le climat se tend
oui avec un coup de chaud annoncé en
allemagne rapporte le journal la croix
inflation prix l'énergie surtout hausse
de la pauvreté
la première économie européenne
n'échappe pas à la crise les
manifestations se multiplient depuis
plusieurs semaines et le gouvernement
allemand craint de vivre un automne
social très mouvementée notamment à
cause des risques de coupure du gaz
russe dont dépend très fortement notre
voisin et puisqu'on parle de factures en
voici une queue dont on parle peu pour
l'instant mais qui devrait être payée
par le contribuable britannique - on
parle évidemment des funérailles de la
reine elizabeth 2 dont le coût est
estimé à 35 millions d'euros alors je
précise qu'il ne s'agit pas encore d'un
chiffre officiel mais seulement d'une
estimation et il ne s'agit pas seulement
du coût des funérailles mais aussi du
fait que ce lundi 19 septembre qui sera
donc un jour historique on l'a bien
compris mais aussi un jour férié
outre-manche nef et bien cela évidemment
aura un impact sur l'économie
britannique le problème et c'est tout ça
arrive dans un contexte extrêmement
compliquée sur le plan économique avec
une inflation qui a dépassé les 10% dans
le royaume du jamais vu depuis 40 ans
forcément ça fait grincer des dents du
côté autres des antimonarchistes 20% de
la population dénoncerait le faste liés
à ces funérailles c'est ce que nous
rapportent nos voisins de rfi mais ce
n'est pas tant la reine qui est visé
c'est surtout le système monarchique
dans son ensemble on peut on lit que le
sist la famille royale coûte 50 millions
d'euros à la royaume uni chaque année
pour les défenseurs du royaume et bien
en recettes touristiques ça rapporte
plus le roi charles iii lui a déjà
promis de réduire le train de la famille
royale après les funérailles il se dit
qu'au royaume uni la famille royale
coûte à chaque anglais chaque année
l'équivalent d'une bouteille de lait on
prend la direction de l'est avec cette
avance éclair de l'armée ukrainien
depuis plusieurs jours qui surprend les
observateurs envoyés plusieurs milliers
de kilomètres carrés elle en a parlé sur
nos antennes ces derniers jours des
villes de l'est auparavant contrôlés par
le russe libéré c'est le retour de
l'espoir titre la croix qui met
toutefois en avant la possibilité d'une
riposte russe dans les semaines ou les
mois à venir c'est aussi l'occasion pour
la presse internationale de se pencher
sur les exactions commises par l'armée
russe durant sept ans d'occupation le
guardian vous le voyez ici donne la
parole à des habitants 10e récemment
libérés évoquant l'horreur de
l'occupation avec notamment plusieurs
cas de disparition au sentiment de
soulagement se mêlent aussi le chagrin
et des jours passés rapporte la bbc en
langue russe plusieurs cas de torture
ont été répertoriés d'après la chaîne
britannique un homme témoigne il dit
avoir été gardé en captivité pendant 40
jours dans la région de rares kif
plusieurs habitants racontent les mêmes
histoires une politique de la terreur
qui va certainement laisser des traces
malgré les récentes victoires de l'armée
craignait avant de nous quitter on va
prendre la direction des étoiles mais
pas forcément de ce qu'on croit oui on
va prendre la direction de dubaï en fait
avec saint projet qui vise le tourisme
spatial mais pas au delà de notre
atmosphère mais bien sur terre on sait
que c'est très cher que s'est soumis à
un cercle très privé surtout que c'est
très nocifs pour l'environnement et bien
dubaï projet de fabriquer une lune
géante sur sur sur ses terres en fait
une sorte de complexe hôtelier de spy de
plein de choses de ce genre de ce type
avec toutefois un centre d'entraînement
spatiale pour les agences spatiales
celles ci n'ont pas dit si elle était
intéressée par le projet coût de
l'opération 5 milliard de dollars je ne
sais pas encore combien coûtera la nuit
d'hôtel mais ça sera certainement assez
cher avec tout ça on en oublierait
presque qu'il ya un vrai voyage vers la
lune qui s'organisent en ce moment même
en floride c'est la mission artemis donc
ils devaient partir fin août prochain
dans une prochaine date de lancement
prévue pour l'instant le 27 septembre si
tout va bien on peut très bien vous avez
oublié pour la lune par n'ont pas encore
ou pour dubaï non pas encore mais
bientôt merci beaucoup julien schell
d'avoir tourné